as a fire marshal in New York John Knox  was a legend he investigated hundreds of  fires in the 70s and 80s terrorist  bombings - he founded the Fire Marshal's  benevolent association it was all part  of a life of service Knox was a combat  engineer with the Marines in Korea after  a brief stint in the New York City  Police Department he joined the fire  department in 1960 he was 100% about  integrity says Zack Knox the third of  his father's four children he wouldn't  do anything for his own career at the  risk of his men after 9/11 Knox came out  of retirement to help dig through the  rubble at Ground Zero work that would  damage his lungs til the end Knox wore a  gold embossed Fire Marshal's ring given  to him after 30 years of service even in  the hospital he didn't want to take it  off John Knox was 84  [Music]